well cheers to that i will drink again
for that just for y'all
um well i just noticed i don't know what
was really going on that day
wait i just noticed that we all have
margaritas except you paula
uh where are you i know i don't know
what it is can you not drink where you
are
i don't have anything here to drink
so i'm just drinking water i'm hydrating
um your home looks a lot like my green
room
oh really yup yup it really does
i always thought that we had similar
tastes
are you in my green room
are you here ma'am
no oh my gosh
what are you i will bring you what are
you there for the snacks in the cup i
have a comfy couch and i
look i will bring you to get you out
here justin bring another margarita
here we go look at this margarita i'm
waiting for you paula
this is friendship in the making come on
get out here if you want it you came all
the way down here
okay okay
well everybody this is a tour of our
back stage
[Laughter]
and way to go no you're great way to go
mixologist back there
your your green room is much nicer than
any other
lean to that i was going to be in oh
you're coming all the way from the band
i can't believe it
sorry about that hi guys oh here let me
give this to somebody
i don't know if you need the drink
you're already knocking stuff over
give it up oh there are my girls
[Music]
you